as some states begin reopening their
economies many restaurant owners are
concerned they will have to move tables
further apart for social distancing
making it even harder to make the kind
of revenue they need to be viable for
more on this let's wait it looks like we
maybe have Kelly
all right we have Kelly and Conway we're
going to talk about restaurants we
didn't have Kelly in and now we have
Kelly Anne good to have you welcome I
I've been here I think we had some
technical difficulties we can talk about
restaurants we get to talk about deals
with the Senate in the house let's start
right there because in all seriousness
are a lot of people small business
owners have been emailing me for a week
or so saying they've heard the President
and Democratic leaders tout the PPP and
yet some of them can't get through the
SBA they can't get their banks to
actually loan them money
what's your assurances to them this
morning that the SBA and the president
got to get to the bottom of that and
where are we on a deal for more money
the president is committed to doing that
I heard today from a legislative affairs
team that they are hopeful we can get a
deal this week and that deal should
infuse a whole bunch more of cash
billions of dollars for these small
business owners these mom-and-pop said
who you're hearing from I'm hearing from
we're all hearing from that they want to
stay afloat but they need this money to
enable them to make payroll to cover
some of their expenses and overhead and
we've seen these terrible stories
Harvard got nine nine million out of the
cares Act and some people are very much
object to that they've got about a 41
billion dollar endowment up at Harvard
I'm sure that they thought they should
participate in it companies like Shake
Shack have returned their ten million
dollar loan because they recognize that
those for whom this was intended to help
the most are those who need it the most
in ER and are suffering the most
those mom-and-pop shops you know the
local stores in your community not the
franchises so that money will be there
also in this neutron chip money will be
about seventy five billion more for
hospitals twenty five billion more for
testing more for emergencies so it's
supposed to be more flushed with cash
and I fully encourage people to keep on
applying for the loans and these grants
because it's there for them so that's
big picture but let's get specific then
and try to nail this down where are we
in terms of the Treasury secretary
Stephen minuchin Democratic leader
Schumer Republican leader McConnell the
whole gang where are we at this hour on
actually getting a deal well the
secretary feels a very confident said
that yesterday that a deal is happening
much better position than we were say a
week ago and let's be fair this
president has taken immediate action
every time one of these relief packages
related to kovat has hit his desk he has
signed it that 2.2 trillion several
weeks ago he signed it immediately and
may I remind all Americans fortunately
edie that cares Act passed the Senate
unanimously 96 to nothing it was
bicameral both chambers and bipartisan
and we want people to know this is not
being overly politicized when it comes
to the President's desk on the way there
sometimes it is and I would say you know
when when majority leader in the house
Steny Hoyer said well Congress is now
recessed until May 4th unless there's a
cord emergency hey folks we're in an
emergency we're working here every
single day seven days a week at this
White House and across this country
people have mobilized private and public
sector mobilized I'm sure all governors
are working overtime as well with their
teams so we need Congress to get back
here and make this happen for the
American people they should not be at
home they should be here in Washington
getting this money funded for our small
business owners and and getting out to
the President's desk we're also hearing
stories from some of our Catholic
schools want to shut down they need to
shut down because of the Cova burdens I
think some of this money should be
intended for operations like that if
they qualify under 500 so you're talking
about mom-and-pop says you're also
talking about these these companies in
these outfits these nonprofits that
people aren't even really considering
would be so financially impacted by this
and we want to be able to have them
apply as well and help them hey Kelly
Ann it's Sandra obviously the White
House is monitoring the situation across
the country as the president says he
believes that some governors of some
states have gone too far with their
restrictions on stopping the spread of
kovat 19 you've seen the protests that
have been emerging some even calling for
gatherings on Facebook Mark Zuckerberg
responded to that calling it the spread
of harmful misinformation they've agreed
to take some of those calls for protests
down
what is the president saying about that
this morning the fact that these
protests are calling for the end of some
of the guidelines that he's set to begin
with well first and foremost we want
people to adhere to the CDC guidelines
and we've updated those Sandra about
less than two weeks ago for the 16
critical infrastructure industries
people should read those guidelines we
need physical distancing of six feet
where that face covering that mask
certainly practiced some of the protests
there but some of the protesters clearly
seen the pictures are breaching those
breaching that social distancing line
correct but at the same time some of
these governors have physically
distanced from common sense in Michigan
you can basically smoke your grass but
not cut your grass this makes no sense
to many people and so for them this is
not fomenting domestic rebellion I look
at those people and I see the Forgotten
men have forgotten women economically
they're saying look I'm in a low
infection area I'm a symptomatic not
exposed I want to get back to work and
let's be fair today's April 20th
we have millions tens and millions of
Americans right now staring at Mays
bills how are they going to meet these
bills in May their rent their mortgage
the food for their children basic
necessities in their households and
they're saying I want to get back to
work the governor's have the last word
on that many of them are working on that
but some have been more concerned about
I think controlling the populations and
protecting them and the president is
just making that clear but it's the
president's guidelines is the federal
guidelines that are out there that
everybody should be adhering to I
wondered Kellyanne if we had dr. Peter
Hotez on earlier and every expert
including him says look we've got to
increase and ramp up testing but he told
us he wants to ask you directly as a
medical expert is the White House he
understands we all understand mayors
governors everyone carries some
responsibility here but he said it's
going to take the White House to get
people back to work by by pushing the
CDC to have some national guidelines and
standards so that mayors and governors
in every state municipality know what's
going on with testing is the White House
going to take that responsibility I've
got some good news there first of all
testing is the most frequently echoed
word here at the White House these days
including in the task force meetings
which I participated in daily we're very
focused on testing first is diagnostic
and so for that testing we had about
85,000 a month ago we're now at four
million we'll be at five million by the
end of this month so that's ramped up
significantly and it's ramped up in the
type of testing also you see at Rutgers
saliva test you see this rapid Abbot
test you see folks really trying to the
FDA are proving different testing so
that more people can access that but
there's also surveillance testing for
surveillance and there's certainly also
serology testing they've talked about
and I think the great news I have for
you today is in about 20 minutes the
Vice President is expected to lead a
call with our nation's governor's the DC
mayor the heads of the territories again
he had one on Thursday with the
president and they will be talking about
testing one thing dr. Burks is
emphasizing to these to these governors
is we we did about 150,000 tests we're
doing about 150,000 I think a day we can
double that if they ramped up the
capacity they have in their state so dr.
Burks has put together a map that shows
you what your testing capacity is in
your own state hoping that these private
labs like quests and lab core your
hospital labs your public labs that
everybody knows what is in their state
it's similar not completely now this was
similar to what was going on with the
ventilators which is yes we are going to
supply them what do you have in your
state what you actually need we want to
supply the need not the ask so there's
no question I think dr. Brooks is
telling me today we have nine platforms
at about a thousand labs and that for
both the antibody and nucleic testing
that you know you need specificity and
sensitivity that we're working on now
but everybody agrees that that is where
this is headed next it is not a perfect
system but we've been building that
ecosystem around the clock
what is also difficult to perfect is
just how exactly to reopen the country
and get the economy going again this is
an incredibly challenging decision for
everyone involved Kellyanne how
confident is the president in that may
1st date for starting to reopen some our
areas of the country this morning Sandra
I would remind everybody that there is a
three-phase approach to reopening that
we have published it was announced last
week everybody can access that I'm sure
it's on whitehouse.gov/live foxnews.com
that's easy to access
and the reason there are phases is
because this is data-driven not date
driven we have from the beginning always
been listening to the medical
professionals and the scientist and we
will continue to do that I was very
pleased to hear dr. Fowler publicly say
what he has said privately which is that
he thinks that there's enough testing
for phase one you can look at his exact
quote that we can you know if you're
looking at phase one we can start with
that but we all recognize the balance
that is necessary we net recognizes is
first a medical crisis but also
financial crisis for many of our
hard-hit households in this country but
if you look at those three phases it's
never intended to just turn on the the
button a light switch this is more
gradual and it really depends on
infection rates hospital capacity ICU
capacity ventilator capacity in your
area it also matters if you were ever
exposed if you're asymptomatic I mean
let's face it in one workplace you may
have a perfectly healthy 28 year old
male who lives alone was never exposed
as asymptomatic he may be in a very
different situation than a colleague
who's 50 years older than him and it has
been exposed or is is symptomatic so I'm
sure that the employer will be taking
care of both of them but one may be able
to return to work and one may have to
wait you see what's doing cabinet wide
and administration wide also where
you've got sonny perdue 19 billion more
to help our farmers and the the
meatpacking industry so we are looking
at industry by industry geography by
geography and never suggesting that you
just turn on the light switch we just
want to make sure people see that look
the governor's want the last say and the
president said great you have the last
say on whether or not or how to reopen
your economies but somehow they want to
delegate and abdicate all the testing to
the federal government we've got to work
together and I'm very happy as someone
who's been on all these governor's calls
with the president vice president I hear
an awful lot of collaboration not
competition and not frustration on those
calls I think some people go on other
networks some governor's go to other
networks and they sing a different tune
but there's been a great deal of
responsiveness and collaboration between
these governors and the federal
government that will continue as we
gradually reopen pieces of the economy
Kellyanne what about the collaboration
or lack thereof with the Speaker of the
House as you know Nancy Pelosi was on
with our colleague Chris Wallace on Fox
News son
yesterday among other things she said
the president is a weak leader and she
said that he has failed in the
coronavirus response you say it was such
a disappointing interview from the
Speaker of the House who's sitting in
her home not feeling isolated
economically desperate like so many
Americans are right now probably people
in her own district and I thought it was
very disappointing for her to just name
call and disparage the president
personally rather than say I'm getting
Congress back to work this week so we
can get more money for these small
business owners to stay afloat for them
it's not a matter of prosperity its
survival right now and it shouldn't just
be survival of the fittest it should not
be Darwinism or discrimination because
you're a small business who's going
inventory by inventory or paycheck to
paycheck we should be helping them that
was the whole point of the PPP under the
Small Business Administration and
Treasury and I felt that when you've got
nothing positive to say you know small
minds talk about other people they don't
talk about big issues and I felt it was
incredibly disappointing instead of her
showing bipartisanship as we've seen all
across this country in so many ways have
you ever seen the country's people and
businesses mobilize in such a positive
responsive uplifting way as we have over
the last five weeks
saundra Ned it's really remarkable to
seen as a mother of four school-aged
children it's been fantastic to point
out in a completely non-political
fashion how many Americans and how much
American businesses and volunteers have
stood up offering to help with the food
banks offering to have their their
parking lots be stand up field medical
hospitals or testing sites for example
and then we have the Speaker of the
House or Kelly chocolate is so smart and
so powerful not say I'm going to make
sure the money is there but Kellyanne
just to follow up on some of the video
that we've been playing while you've
been speaking it's areas in the country
where we are seeing these protests to
circle back to that point and what the
president is saying about that this
morning
is he concerned that while they might be
protesting protesting what they say or
see are the right reasons to get back to
work or
feel like they're overly restricted is
the president is the White House task
team concern that they might be
spreading the virus at the same time
while they're gathering
look we've took great action the
president took immediate action by
banning travel from China under
tremendous criticism including by
full-on members of the crash tag
resistance in the media many of them and
he has saved millions of lives and so
doing so we're the ones have the 30 day
15 days to slow the spread and an
additional 30 to slow the spread so
we're second to no 1 in terms of saying
do what you must to slow the spread and
keep it that way but Sandra where we
ever intended to have the entire
government and our economy shut down
until we have a vaccine that's really
the balance people have to know we have
to learn how to live with the live with
the virus while we're doing testing
while we're doing therapeutics while
we're developing a vaccine and the
president is not saying hey this state
that community those kinds of workers in
that industry go go go but remember we
also have critical infrastructure
workers have never stopped working our
truckers our sanitation our food workers
certainly are amazing heroic health care
workers and first responders so that
gives you a good roadmap as to how to
reopen pieces of the economy sensibly on
it and smartly and we know as you said
the group of Governors will be meeting
with the president this morning we look
forward to an update from that Kellyanne
Conway at the White House thank you
thank you both take care